[Music]
so so you think you can dance it's still
going it's on it's what like seventeenth
season or something how do you feel
about the show it's a different show now
i think well oh there's 17 seasons
what's the best season who's the best
judge the best season honestly the best
season
it was probably
i don't know maybe like seasons three to
five or something season one it wasn't
my season my season was a [ __ ] uh
train wreck why is the first one well
it's the only season that had a
different host do you guys remember that
uh jeff bezos cheated on his wife with
this woman named lauren sanchez she was
the host my season oh really did you
ever ask her about business she asked
her about it back then
yeah
was she a dancer no she was a like a
broadcast journalist i think something
like that but uh yeah i mean my season
was just like they were just kind of
freestyling it because they didn't know
what was going on well tv was different
back then too it was more like they
wanted drama so it was like i think we
had producers from like survivor or some
[ __ ] like working on it to make it like
crazy but yeah uh something just
happened on there they have to let one
of the judges go
which just hear about that
uh matthew morrison who's that from glee
looks like this did they uncover some
tweets oh yeah he's a curly haired
[ __ ] glee i remember that yeah
must have been credited incorrectly
[Laughter]
dude i just remember
every time i saw a greek commercial i
was like damn that guy has an even more
punchable face than me somehow
yeah
so he was a judge on the panel they had
to let him go because of in a he had an
inappropriate they're gonna call it
inappropriate relationship
what he calls it was that he was just
texting a contestant
um
and uh
in his text i guess like the person felt
uncomfortable thought it was like a late
night flirty type thing what do you say
you want to go get some orange juice
no it was like he just said he wanted to
discuss some things but did he have to
meet face to face it was it was it was a
very very
it's very vast what was it like was it a
week it was just like hi this is matthew
um
would love to connect and talk about
some things or something i'm
paraphrasing and he said it was because
that person
that was a contestant had expressed
interest in a particular choreographer
that he actually knew so he thought he
could connect them
but he didn't say that he just like said
that vague you know little thing
and no one knows that's really what he
said because he he uh
he recorded a video of himself like
explaining like yeah this is all i said
as i quote and he starts reading it but
it doesn't like show it he's just like
hello hello he's like not [ __ ]
showing it to you all right but
i do know at least from when i was on
there it doesn't matter what you're
saying you just can't be taught it's a
breach of contract regardless yeah so
judges can't talk to contestants just
period because it does seem kind of
shameful upset not like personally like
that yeah because like what if they're
being like hey i'll i'll i'll let you
win number one if you give me some money
or like whatever
i mean it's also just like a standard
and practices thing it's like every show
that exists on tv you're not there's
like supposed to be dividing lines to
keep fairness how about former
contestants i don't think that matters
it's like more if you're in the contest
it's like as if you're like you know
like it's like playing uh
it's like playing [ __ ] wheel of
fortune and you're having a side
conversation with pat sager and if you
really did want to help this dancer out
he could have had his team reach out to
this person and they could connected
this choreographer together like it
didn't have to be him yeah that's the
other thing like you weren't i bet you
weren't texting the [ __ ] abdc judges
and [ __ ] i mean they could talk to you
if you're there but that's the whole
point is that you're just
even when i was on so you think you just
can't like
you know you just can't do that i mean
like even smack when she tried out for
so you think and dietrix was a judge and
it's like we're all like the
connection's so close even then you
can't just be hanging out or talking
because that's the competition it's like
yeah it's biased i like preserve
fairness but the the main thing is
another reason why they even have that
um that rule in places so this [ __ ]
doesn't happen
so you can't use this power to flirt
well just if you even have to just like
if you even have to explain to the
public guys this is what i was saying
it's like you're past the point of
[ __ ] up already it's not what you
think it is it doesn't even matter the
content it's not exactly like you've
already breached your contract therefore
conversation
is it a crime though to make friends
contract what i mean don't we understand
couldn't have wait until after the show
nope because i'm friendly yeah
that's what i mean like it's not like
she can immediately go to work she's
just still in the [ __ ] competition
who did he text was it a big deal
was it a who a big titty lady
do we need that's the missing variable
that's critical information you got it
that's a part of the evidence though if
i was in court and steve was like
exhibit a this is who he texted big
titty lady and then i would be like oh
he's guilty dude this was so guilty
or if he was texting me you'd be like ah
objection
on
he was not texting a big titty lady
clearly and then he goes like this flat
chest and then turn sideways
profile for the jury please thank you
there it is i think what he did was just
a basic breach it's so freaking basic
and you would only do this if you really
thought you wouldn't get trouble if you
think you're in touch do you think this
guy's stupid
you think matthew morrison's like i'm
untouchable i'm a god in this city i was
on glee that's another thing right there
it's like you're not some new guy to the
industry you've been working here for so
freaking long yeah and you've been on
good shows you understand that there is
lines drawn between different
departments and people why even put
yourself in that position though so he's
been a judge for a while
no they just started the season like for
like security [ __ ] up i think he was
trying to get at that person i think i
think he was trying to you know
hollywood i think so because why else
would he cross the text messages he
won't show it you just show him if you
got nothing to hide sean he was beating
it up i think on glee a little bit
because him and liam michelle apparently
had a thing
liam michelle the chick from glee the
lead on glee she was the kid on the show
and he was the detroiter show yeah and
he was beating it up
oh [ __ ] significantly yeah significantly
he dips his pen and the company no no
he's being happy oh beating it up yeah
that's a different connotation yeah
significant amounts that's different
that's why you're not supposed to [ __ ]
your co-workers dude that's wrong you
don't [ __ ] where you eat huh where did
you get that from oh leah uh talked
about it oh openly yeah wow said it yeah
there you go i think she had a book or
something i don't know i wasn't really
listening to her mouth you know what i
mean
oh god
supporters of women oh yeah yeah that's
right that's right no no i don't
remember exactly where i heard it
i believe we believe out of character
out of control oh look we have no we
believe all we want we're gonna pull it
up we're gonna pull it up steve's gonna
find it yeah i'm fine so i i also don't
think it i mean i know there's like kind
of a stigma that exists over like glee
people that they're kind of like
no they've had a lot of [ __ ] tragedy
like oh yeah yeah like the girl that
passed away in the river nia rivera and
the dude that killed himself and the
dude that got caught with child porn to
like a magnitude never seen
leah michelle admits she dated glee
co-star matthew morrison a curly-headed
[ __ ]
from entertainment weekly that's what
they said
and they said it on record he's like
curly had a [ __ ] he was really happy is
that on variety no i believe it i super
i super judge
all of the people that do these shows
where they appear so clean cut because i
feel like that's that's a dead giveaway
that's like yeah that's like repression
you know
it's not real it's not like bob shaggett
like that kind of look and then when he
comes out he's just like hardcore you
know he was our guardian he was
but he was also a little bit too known
for being america's dad and stuff
and so he
it was kind of a little ed lordian like
sometimes the way he would come out and
be like no i say [ __ ] a lot i see him
saying [ __ ] right now so yes
he dialed it back later but he i
remember in the 90s he was really trying
to do a lot of that because he was
really like kind of figuring out his
image still because he was like
conflicted about all that [ __ ] it was
pretty interesting i'm actually a comic
guys so you guys everywhere there's a
consensus here that you guys are all
convinced that this dude was trying to
hit on her like it wasn't well
especially if the pretense is not to
talk to the contestants
i know that i don't know yeah all i know
is that you've reached a contract
you've been in this game long enough to
know yeah and um
why even put yourself in that position i
like to blindly accuse you yeah you
should so yeah for me i'm like he's
guilty dude
he's guilty of breaching the contract
that's what he's guilty of you guys have
no empathy i'll say this he's guilty
what are you immediately
[Applause]
i'll be part of the legal team okay sure
we all know that he likes to [ __ ] at
work
right because he likes his [ __ ] where he
eats this guy so that's what i'm saying
so that makes it more likely that he was
in fact fishing for
some fresh evidence is good yeah you
know what but you know what i i feel i
feel like i want to be a proponent for
friendship and you guys have no heart
you have no empathy
it's a different joke you're you're a
superstar already have friends have your
own friends
come come to come to set with your
friends all right being a cook yeah
trying to connect with the simple people
bro he's trying to connect with the
simple people the normal people i just
don't think he ever thought it would get
out like i don't think he would ever
think that it would be a situation how
did it get out she came forward see this
is why you should ask if power making an
assumption not when you're blindly
accused
you've got a reptile this is right
standards this is my thing okay
he came forward and said that he made
her uncomfortable so then the fox did in
their own investigation so that's a key
thing right there they didn't just go
okay no they did their own investigation
at the end of it they came to the
decision that you need to go but what if
he was right about
to talk about his feelings and then
she's the dots are just blinking on his
texts yeah but it doesn't matter though
signed a contract and that's i think
that's where the line is drawn and
that's we're on the same team i'm with
you before this before the detail before
the detail that it was a girl came out
the headline already came out that like
oh uh matthew morrison is leaving the
show due to breaching his uh contractual
obligations as a judge that's all it say
everybody was like i
was trying to hit on somebody and then
this came out later
and they're like oh yeah that was
true i'm just mad about the breaching
the contract that's what i'm at about
he's upset because he thinks like uh
like if you go to his social media like
everyone on there is like if there's a
picture of his wife they're like
really you don't think she's pretty
enough you couldn't just be satisfied
with that you gotta go out and try to
like
he's got tons of [ __ ] even like uh even
articles about this at the top of the
header it'll say trigger warning matthew
morrison no
his name is a [ __ ] trigger warrior
hey it triggered me years ago and but a
different way you know what what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna go on my instagram
i'm gonna comment on the picture of him
and his wife and say you shouldn't have
breached contract that's what i'm saying
that's it bro that's what i'm saying
yeah bro hey you shouldn't have breached
contracts
by by the way big fan big fan
love season season three was my favorite
episode before we discuss this i just
want to say trigger warning for people
who are not into breaching contracts
you turn this video off turn the camera
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you